he's my favorite creating mass
destruction the old-school way meant
taking objects and manually scoring them
at their breaking points which is
breaking it apart and putting it back
together for later destruction kind of
like that vase I broke and glue it back
together in fifth grade and then just
being honest it's a watershed moment for
me putting it out there had to come
clean to it right it's the first step
and then you were at the mercy of the
real-world physics as to how the models
destructive destructed did they fall in
the right direction would they hit other
buildings and you only got one take to
do it as filmmakers come up with
spectacular ways for aliens to destroy
global landmarks digital artists have
come up with better solutions to give
them more control when roland emmerich
needed to demolish Los Angeles in the
film 2012 he went to digital domain for
the answer the artists at digital domain
used an open-source software called
bullet a physics engine which included
tools for rigid body dynamics
simulations bulla was developed for
real-time use in video games but it's
rapid approximate simulation of vast
numbers and rigid bodies made it
attractive for large-scale destruction
simulation sony image works was quick
stat quick to integrate bullet into
their destruction system while
simultaneously Digital Domain also
started developing the drop destruction
toolkit incorporating bullets engine and
helping guide it toward a focus on the
scale and detail required for motion
pictures the result was the spectacular
annihilation of our beloved City of
Angels
at nearly the same time a developer at
Sony Pictures Imageworks was doing the
same thing with their pipeline the
combination of influence on bullet from
both Sony and Digital Domain made the
tool useful for the broader visual
effects community the Academy presents a
technical achievement award to Owen
Komen's for his development of the
bullet physics library and 2 NAAFI spins
afar and Stephen Marshall for their
separate development of the to
large-scale destruction systems based on
bullet gentlemen placemark
Thank You Myles and Margo I accept this
award on behalf of the entire drop
development team Mart Martin Laursen REO
sakaguchi Michael Clive from Sampath
Tenma Seth and Dave Stevens and also the
entire digital domain effects department
I want to thank my colleagues at Digital
Domain DreamWorks and oriental
DreamWorks for going along with all of
my harebrained ideas I want to thank my
mentor Doug Roble I want to thank my
parents for all of their love and
support and I'd like to dedicate my
award to my father for teaching me to
persevere against very difficult
problems
thank you very much unlike most people
here the bullet physics library is just
a hobby of mine so sometimes people ask
you how many - how much time in your
current job do you spend on bullets I
say oh not percent basically so at the
track basically Sony Computer
Entertainment and AMD and Google - let
me work even a percent of my time which
they do actually for the last 10 years
which I'm very thankful for for that for
that for supporting open-source
basically and of course I thank my wife
beautiful wife in the kimono over there
and my my son Oscar which I called for
special reason Oscar and Nina which both
of them are upstairs and last but most
important I thank the supporters of the
bullet physics library and contributors
thank you
as certainly an incredible honor but the
Sony Destruction pipeline wouldn't have
been possible without the contributions
of Dave Davies Sasha Marissa Posse Chris
Allen and Scotch in ermine and all the
effects artists over the years who have
we used it and actually drive it forward
Thanks